hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is an
in-depth breakdown of Game of Thrones
season 7 episode 2 Stormborn so as we do
every week on these in-depth breakdowns
on new rockstars I'm going to dig deep
into the visuals and the themes all
these miserable moments all these
details that you might have missed I'm
going to point out some of these subtle
connections to the books and past
episodes and maybe some parallels to
history yeah this wasn't just an episode
about eunuch sex and pirate battles
there's some stuff for the nerds too if
you haven't already be sure to check out
Westeros weekly that's Phillip in mod
show that answers all of your questions
and make some predictions about next
episode ok so let's get started with the
opening images this episode opens on
this Thunder storm raging over the
cliffs of Dragonstone
Tyrion actually points out that Daenerys
was born in this exact kind of storm
which of course is the origin of her
namesake Daenerys Stormborn
now some background on this Daenerys is
mother Queen rhaella named her Daenerys
Stormborn because of this famous storm
that happened during the birth and this
was actually while they were in exile
from King's Landing after Robert's
rebellion Kayla actually died in
childbirth Stormborn is also the title
of this episode so let's talk about what
this might mean what does it mean to be
Stormborn well based off of what the
characters are going through this
episode it seems that to be Stormborn
means to be tested means that you've
arrived into this world as the person
you are now under tumult and difficulty
you're stronger than the average person
basically Stormborn is the water version
of the term trial-by-fire
and it seems that fire has been more of
the element that Daenerys is embraced
not water she even says in its first
scene that she doesn't remember her
birth that she feels no connection to
the storm or to this home island really
of her endless titles that she's rattled
off every episode Stormborn it's
probably the title that she mentioned
the leaf more often she goes by mother
of dragons or the unburnt the breaker of
chains therefore I think this opening
scene it's really foreshadowing Daenerys
is defeat in this episode she does not
show the qualities that this episode
considers Stormborn although fun
background detail dust storm that
Daenerys is born then actually destroyed
what was left of the Targaryen fleet
from that war so yeah this episode is
showing history repeating itself
just like last episode did it showed the
victory of Daenerys returning to a guns
table preparing for her conquest
contrastingly this episode shows the
defeat of Daenerys revisiting her
families rock bottom okay so in this
scene in the math room of Dragonstone we
finally see Daenerys and Varys speak to
each other and there's this interesting
clash where Daenerys takes the words out
of varys's mouth this is a callback to
season one when Illyria placated her
brother Viserys by telling him the same
exaggeration now generic shows that
she's smart enough to see through it all
so I think she's using these words
specifically to threaten Varys remember
Varys had that connection to Illyrio and
he used interests in this sneaky master
plot against Robert we saw this in that
scene in season one where Arya overheard
the two of them talking about it
actually interesting coincidence in that
scene Arya is hiding in the skull of
this massive dragon which might be
Valyrian we see this same location in
these same dragon skulls in this episode
and it's kind of a minor detail but
notice how Daenerys wipes her hands as
she walks away from the table almost
like she doesn't want to get her hands
dirty in this coming war and the only
reason I mentioned that is last episode
when she arrived on the beaches of
Dragonstone she specifically put her
hand on the sand allowing the soil of
Dragonstone to get on a prom now it
seems like she wants nothing to do with
it so in this fire exchange and there
it's accused as Varys of being a
conspirator not a loyal servant she
considers disloyal conspirators to be
inconsistent and ultimately foolish
we're at various defends himself saying
he only cares about the realm now it's
interesting to think about various in
terms of some historical figures that
may have inspired his character in the
past Varys has been compared to a man
named Cardinal Richelieu he was the
right-hand man of king louis xiv of
france like Varys hopes to do Cardinal
Richelieu worked behind the scenes
bringing about major reforms that
benefitted most people in France but
really richly only served one king I
think a closer inspiration is someone
named Joe Gow now Zhao Gao was a close
aide to three different emperors in the
Qin Dynasty of China back before 200 BC
Xiao Gao was rumored to be a eunuch just
like Varys there was a theory that he
was actually related to the previous
dynasties
shall dynasty that was a family that the
Qin destroyed and castrated several of
the young men including some people
believe Zhao Gao and his brothers they
believe that jag out secretly plotted to
destroy the Qin from the inside in fact
he's credited for bringing about their
downfall
Zhao Gao is known for the idiom of
calling a deer a horse he used that to
test loyalty when he was about to commit
treason there's actually counsels terian
to do a similar thing in season two now
there's a third famous behind the scenes
powerful figure from history that Varys
is often compared to but there's
actually another character who better
fits that mold they'll talk about them
in a second okay moving on to the throne
room where Daenerys needs the red lady
Melisandre I think Melisandre is
greeting to her is wise I'm a lot of
different levels first off she greets
her in high Valyrian remember that
Daenerys is native tongue and she uses
her background as a slave to praise
Daenerys as a breaker of chains again
kind of stroking her ego and she's smart
to come to her as a red priestess
because Daenerys credits the red priests
for helping bring peace to murine
meanwhile various sees Melisandre as a
threat and I think that's because
Melisandre is a character that I think
is drawn from another character from
history specifically Rasputin so
Rasputin was a mysterious figure who was
close to the family of Tsar Nicholas ii
of russia during the turn of the century
Rasputin was a very weird figure he was
a mystic who convinces our Nicholas that
he had magical powers and many believe
that that ended up leading to the doom
of this dynasty it was that same kind of
suspicion that sir Davos had for
Melisandre when she was counseling
Stannis Baratheon but really the big
bombshell the scene has to do with that
theory of the prince that was promised
or in this case the princess that was
promised big props to miss Andi for
using grammar and translation to clear
up the biggest mystery left on the show
so now that we know that it can be a
princess that was promised this
definitely makes Daenerys the leading
contender let's quickly run down the
different ways she fits this description
she was born beneath a bleeding star
there was that red comet this guy around
the time when she emerged added a
funeral pyre unburnt and he can also say
at that time she was born amidst salt
and smoke smoke of course for the fire
and salts were the tears that she was
crying also if you look at other
interpretations of the prince that was
promised theory she does have this
connection with dragons and she is up
arian lineage the only that's missing is
it doesn't look like Daenerys has any
kind of flaming sword but Melisandre has
made it clear that Daenerys isn't
necessarily alone the prince that was
promised that prophesies are dangerous
things but she does have a part to play
along with another Jon Snow who does
have something that could very likely be
Lightbringer so let's double check that
translation maybe it's not a prince or
princess but a prince and a princess
also I like this little detail here when
Tyrion tells Daenerys that he is an
excellent judge of character you look
closely you can see very smiling in the
background yes Tyrion did very strongly
vouch for him in the previous scenes and
the camera cuts to Daenerys who smiles
as well alright moving on to Winterfell
we get the shot of arrows hitting target
and the specific framing of the shot is
a callback to season one remember bran
was taking aim and then Arya stole his
thunder what's interesting about this is
that at that time it was still
considered unorthodox for a girl to do
any kind of archery but now we see that
this world has changed we actually
talked last breakdown about how John is
trying to usher in this new era of post
chivalry and we see what that looks like
now both boys and girls are learning how
to wield these weapons so then we see
John reading this letter from Tyrion and
like we like to do with all letters that
appear on the show but zoom in enhance
and try to read it and find secret okay
so the most interesting thing about this
letter is that Tyrion did not include
the phrase bend the knee as Daenerys
Bolton - but Tyrion under mine scenarios
not because he doesn't respect her he
does it because he knows that that
approach wouldn't work on John John is a
stark so Tyrion is actually smarter to
use their mutual hatred of Cersei and
their connection as bastards in their
father's eyes as Hanna the Queen Tyrion
is operating more like a secretary of
state would to a president as a sort of
foreign minister diplomat it's almost
expected for him to soften the tone from
the administration also there's another
little change that maybe didn't catch
rather than use the term summons Tyrion
uses the word invites and really just
these small choices by Tyrion makes them
look far more diplomatic and far more is
the nice welcoming person that Jon
remembers and while John and Davos and
stance are all considering how useful
will be to have allies if the knight
King ever makes it out to the wall I
like how there's as clever transition
we're certainly kind of jumps into this
conversation so the editing is making it
seem like Cersei as part of this debate
but whereas Davos and John are worried
about the invaders from the north Cersei
is worried about the invaders from the
east I also like how there is this
overhead shot of Cersei which parallels
the overhead shot of Daenerys in the
previous scenes now when you compare
them you'll notice that Cersei is higher
up and she's isolated and protected
behind her Kingsguard
whereas Daenerys was lower on the same
level she was closer and more vulnerable
open to conversation that shows the
contrast between the two Queens ruling
styles Daenerys is more open to advice
and counsel whereas the source of
circe's pow'r is to make decisions by
herself also notice how the camera cuts
to Jaime's space for two specific
reaction shots first this line from
Cersei and butchy old children without a
second suit and it happens a second time
when she brings up the Mad King so it's
interesting to think about Jaime's inner
monologue throughout all this how
hypocritical is Cersei sounding in the
scene
she and Jaime's children were butchered
- and now Cersei gives them no second
thought and lately she's been acting
like a Mad King herself a tyrant that
Jaime killed to prevent this kind of
cruelty so really it seems like Jaime's
wondering who's the real butcher in
who's the real mad monarch and while we
were comparing Circe's ruling style to
Daenerys is this scene also compares her
to the king in the north notice in her
call to arms to all these southern Lords
she appeals to fear specifically citing
the High Lords that were crucified back
in Mereen and then said to the dragon
she's trying to scare the crap out of
all these guys but it's an exaggeration
the reason Daenerys hasn't attacked
King's Landing it's because she doesn't
want to be the queen of ashes meanwhile
Cersei is more than happy to rule over a
pile of ashes meanwhile comparing this
to jakku in the north John even though
everyone in the north have way more to
fear from the White Walkers an
existential threat to all of them John
keeps his message more about loyalty how
these families have stood by each other
for thousands of years there's actually
a moment later this episode that brings
up this difference between a ruler being
feared or loved and which one's more
valuable now it's actually interesting
in the scene that Lords hardly asked how
to beat dragon and quavering teases a
solution which we find out later is this
giant crossbow and it's appropriate that
Charlie's the one asking because if you
remember his house sigil is of the
archer and while we're talking about
arrow in
there's another layer of humor with
Jamie confusing dickon's name as Rick on
other than dick on just being stupid
name Rick on you'll remember is the
youngest stark son who died of a battle
the bastards last season from an arrow
so when Jamie is talking to Lord Tarly
he appeals to his military reputation
some background here Lord Charlie was
the only army that was successful in
resisting Robert Baratheon in this
rebellion so really what Charlie's
saying here is he's disgusted with the
Kingslayer who of course stabbed his
rival in the back and with the whole
Lannister family for orchestrating the
red wedding where they cut the throats
of the start also in case we didn't
catch this back in that previous game
when you look at all these southern
Lords talking to Cersei Tarly and his
son and his other guy are the only ones
in the room for wearing chainmail
underneath their clothes kind of like
how Roose Bolton did at the red wedding
it's clear that Lord Tarly is such a
cautious and smart military mind that
when he heard about what happened at the
red wedding
he made a rule for himself where he's
never going in the room with Lannisters
unless he's you know dressing in layers
and then when Jaime promises randyll
Tarly to be warden of the south
basically appealing to his ambition and
trying to give the Tarly family name the
meaning with this meaningful transition
to old town to see Charlie's son Sam
boom Randall basically deprived of a
birthright by sending them to the Nights
Watch
so if the sword makes the man who really
is a true Tarly in this case it seems
like the show is saying Sam actually we
see a sword speaking for a man in this
scene archmaester ebro's allows Jorah
Mormont to stay in old town for another
night because he recognizes that his
sword is that of an anointed Knight if
you think about it this sword is kind of
part of what saves Dora's life okay
let's move on to the red keep basement
with Cersei and Clyburn looking at these
dragon skulls longing to Aerys Targaryen
so a little background here the red
keeps throne room when the Mad King
Aerys wasn't charged was filled with
these he was crazy
he claimed he could transform into a
dragon and burn his enemies but of
course the Dragons were extinct so he
just kept up this illusion boozing their
skulls to intimidate anyone who came to
talk to him and then of course torching
people with wildfire as he did with
Ricard and Brandon Stark it's
interesting that she brings that up
because she just did a redecorating
herself she replaced the seven-point
star window and the Baratheon sag
all over King's Landing with her
Lannister lions I was interesting in the
opening credits the irathients AG is
still over King's Landing I'm not
exactly sure why that's the case because
Cersei seems pretty proud of the fact
that she's a Lannister it's not like
she's even pretending to be a Baratheon
anymore but I suppose that from a legal
point of view when you think about all
the other objective authorities around
Westeros and Essos the maesters of old
town the iron bank many of the other
High Lords they probably see Circe's
legal claim to the throne even though
it's super shaky through her connection
to the Baratheon the fact that she was
queen regent of Tommen and Joffrey and
the widow of Robert Baratheon I know it
still feels like it doesn't make total
sense but it's the opening credits who's
really paying attention to those just
kidding we are there's so many
interesting things in these opening
credits actually watch Westeros weekly
because filled-in mod go into a lot of
new cool changes they made and speaking
of game board looking maps
I feel like this scene down in the
basement is meant to be the next step of
the chess game going on between Cersei
and America remember the first time we
saw Cersei last episode she was showing
off her big new war map in the red cape
and the episode ended with Daenerys one
up in her with her own big war map one
designed by her great-great
great-great-great-great- however many
grandfather Aegon but then now Cersei
one-up that by showing that she has
something of Aegon's to the skull of
balerion the dread and on top of that a
weapon that could possibly beat dragon
so do you think this giant crossbow
could actually kill dragon Clyburn is
right we did see spears in Mereen at the
end of season 5 that did wound rogen now
last episode we kind of touched on a
theory based off of stuff in the book
where people are saying that arrows made
out of wood from the weirwood tree could
have some kind of magical power that
could kill a dragon in the books there
was a character named Brandon Snow who
was the bastard brother of Horan Stark
better known as the king who knelt when
Aegon conquered Westeros and flew his
dragons up to Winterfell
Torin was the first king in the north
who realized that there's no way they're
going to defeat these dragon so he melts
allowing the north to be ruled under the
Targaryen but that really pissed off
Brandon who mentioned that he had some
other kind of plan in the works for how
to destroy the dragons and then in
another point in the book bran stark the
one we know has a vision of a young boy
that many believe is branded snow making
arrow
out of wood from a weirwood tree so
we'll see maybe some combination of this
big crossbow and the ammo that's in that
crossbow being made out of something
magical could be the thing that brings
down drogon and the others
kind of like the way silver bullets can
bring down werewolves or kryptonite
smoke grenades can confuse Superman's
for a second now I want to take a moment
to talk about the music of this episode
in the scene you might have noticed that
they're sampling the light of the seven
that was the music from last season's
finale I think the show's going to use
this from this point forward to show
anytime Cersei is making a Power Move so
Cersei discovering this possible weapon
I think the show wants us to connect to
Cersei blowing up the Sept of Baelor and
seriously being chlorinated and while
I'm talking about music later this
episode will use a different memorable
theme to show off a different kind of
transfer of power see how stark theme
which happens when Jon hands off
Winterfell to Sansa we actually hear the
stark music every time there's a
significant stark moment for example
recently we heard it was Jon and Sansa
when they were United last season and
then later in the season when Jon took
back Winterfell from the Bolton's also
this moment of fiber and having Cersei
pull the trigger on this giant crossbow
felt familiar it might be because this
is kind of a recreation of a previous
scene where Cersei son Joffrey seduces
Margaery by having her fire crossbow
which was his favorite weapon in that
scene the arrow goes into the head of a
boar of course the animal that killed
his supposed father's whereas missing
the arrow goes straight through the head
of a dragon some interesting symbolism
there because dragons were always the
animal that Robert felt paranoid about
that's why he forced these heads to be
moved down into the basement where as
Bors was the animal that he should have
feared because that's what ended up
killing him okay let's move on back to
this map room on Dragonstone with this
big strategy meeting so one thing I
noticed about the scene is notice how
Alayna brings up howl of Margery was and
she concludes that it was more essential
for her to be speared she's invoking the
famous political philosopher Machiavelli
he memorably asked if it's better for a
ruler to be feared or loved and
concluded that it's safer to be feared
Machiavelli actually argued that a ruler
should never have firm public
convictions that he should play things
closer to the test that unpredictability
is what makes people theory that
boy it's late that's what Elena is
trying to communicate to Daenerys by
telling her to be the dragon telling her
to be unpredictable don't be pushed
around by these clever schemers use your
own inner strength but if you look past
that Elena is totally using her own
Machiavellian strategy she's plain
Daenerys tears ultimately even though
Daenerys says that she doesn't want to
be queen of the ashes borrowing periods
line that is all Elena once she has
nothing left she just wants to see all
of King's Landing burn so while it's not
the most staged advice it is what a
Lenna ones
okay so Tyrion uses the pieces on this
map table to explain the siege of King's
Landing any planning I actually think
this siege is modeled off of another
famous siege in history the siege of
Yorktown that ended the American War of
Independence against Britain so the way
that work was General Cornwallis who led
the British troops end up isolating
themselves at Yorktown which was
situated on a peninsula facing the
eastern bay of the Chesapeake if you
compare that to the map of Westeros
that's similar geography to King's
Landing but then in that war the French
fleet Bloch hated the bay cutting off
the supply lines and at the same time
American forces split up to block the
British from the north and the West and
this siege lasted a total of three weeks
until the British eventually surrendered
I think this parallels exactly what
Tyrion was to do he was to use the
Dornish on the Greyjoy fleet to block
Blackwater Bay while using the armies
from Highgarden to block them in from
land okay moving on to the hottest scene
of this episode one that didn't involve
discussing jump cuts from dabs to pies
yeah the sex pots that everyone loves to
pause the screen on grey worm and Masson
days I actually think this shot of grey
worms sharpening the blade while the
fire lights it from behind might be a
visual reminder of the moment that he
became a eunuch that's how they had to
do it they had to heat a super sharp
blade - yeah you know no reason I bring
it up as I'm sure it is on grey worms
mind in this scene I also want to point
out how grey worm discusses how the
unsullied masters tested all the
unsullied by using their fears against
them specifically he mentioned that if
someone was afraid of the sea they would
throw them into the sea and if they'd
learn to swim great and if they drowned
well great - because the unsullied were
still stronger that actually sounds a
lot like what the
born do when they baptize people with
the drowned guide they forced them to
drown and if they come back then grape
you're harder and stronger but really I
think this connects to this theme of
this episode what it means to be
Stormborn here grey worm is being tested
with his fear he's finally becoming a
more complete person through this
uncomfortable trial
okay moving back to Old Town in the
library with Sam and arch make cerebro's
so there's a few really interesting
details about the books in the scene if
you're looking closely first one is when
ebro's pulls this book the history of
the Lannister family ebro's talks about
the writer archmaester chavalla 'then he
says he's a dreadful writer about an
excellent researcher and you might
remember that this is the same guy who
wrote a different book that we've seen
on the show before a history of the
great sieges of Westeros remember that's
the book that Tyrion read in season 2
while preparing for the siege of King's
Landing and yes while Tyrion seemed
super bored by this read he did end up
being pretty knowledgeable as a leader
under siege now I'll get to another
awesome detail in a second but while
we're talking about the books of
Westeros I want to say that the reason
we even get to make these videos because
guys who can't do this for free is
because our friends at audible are
sponsoring it audible offers a wide
selection of audiobooks and podcasts and
you can get a free audiobook with a
30-day trial by going to audible.com
slash new rock stars audible is honestly
how I reread or I guess in this case
read listen to the whole a song of ice
afire series and how I catch up on
George RR Martin's fascinating
background on all this stuff I actually
really liked a game of Thrones of family
history
trust me it's way better than arche make
sure to volitans version is again check
out audible.com slash new rock stars or
click on the link in the description to
start your trial today
okay let's get back to the old town
library now you might have noticed this
moment with Sam and archmaester ebro's
when he's talking about the title the
book he went to right now in the past
we've talked about this theory of all
the events and Game of Thrones being
revealed as events in a history book
that will be written by Sam at the end
of the series and maybe this moment is
suggesting that that book will have a
very poetic name of a song of ice and
fire bill demott actually went into this
in westeros weekly to check that out
really I think this idea is just popular
because people might
a moment that's kind of like in Lord of
the Rings where Bilbo Baggins wrote the
manuscript for there and back again
which is the story of The Hobbit
even though j.r.r tolkien was one of
George RR Martin's
inspirations I don't know this just
seems a little too cheeky for George I
think this moment could just be a wink
at that theory but let me know what you
think about this in the comments and
then there's a third interesting author
that's mentioned Sam mentions reading
the study of rare diseases by
archmaester pylos now the name pylos is
a reference to the character just
regular maester Pylos and the book he is
a younger maester who serves Stannis
Baratheon at Dragonstone he replaced
maester Cressen now that Maester did
know Shireen Baratheon so he might have
some expertise on how to treat greyscale
even though maester Cressen was really
the one who cured it but it to me it
seems like the show is just reusing that
name and rhe appropriating it as this
older archmaester from the past now real
quick let's talk about this letter that
jor is writing to Daenerys and of course
let's zoom an Enhanced who the quality
so much better magically so basically
this is super sad depressing because
they came to the fiddle with the last
hopes in the matrix could treat me but
I'm beyond their care also check out the
bottom there I have loved you since the
moment I met you the Shamy stopped
writing because it was just getting good
this is super sad Jorah is basically
admitting that his greyscale will cause
him to lose his mind before too long so
he's writing this letter it's kind of a
video that someone who's dying makes for
their kids to watch after they're dead
but in this case the kid that they're
right in the - is also someone they're
in love with romantically okay I made it
weird but then when Sam comes back and
notice how he brings up George bother
you or Mormont Sam knew him from his
days of the wall and then he says this
here Encanto him today so Jon Sam is
actually returning a favor from a very
specific moment season 2 when George
told him to get his ass in line
Charlie I forbid you to die juden buddy
I think it's interesting how Game of
Thrones keeps bringing up these memories
of fallen fathers Ned Stark's wisdom and
mistakes keep echoing through Jon and
Sansa Tywin Lannister is clearly
inspiring Jaime and search these
decisions and for sure the mad Kings
choices are now haunting Daenerys more
ever and now in its scene we see how G
or Mormont survivalist mindset is
through Sam saving his son despite he
and Jorah being estranged ok enough
emotional father-son stuff let's move on
to aria at the Inn at the crossroads
so yeah just like last week Sam insists
on roastiness house with the editing
last week it was Koopa soup now it's I
guess putz
to PI actually in this scene if you
listen closely the guys at the table
behind aria the addition has got about
how Daenerys plans to lay siege to
King's Landing so these guys are
probably criminals because this is a
callback to the last time King's Landing
with siege back in season 2 in that same
scene that I mentioned earlier
Ron described what happened to a city
under siege the thieves Silva Shh
soon as the gates are sealed they steal
all the food by the time it's all over
they're the richest men in town and now
we see the flipside of that how these
criminals are planning to exploit the
situation actually speaking of season
two it's nice to see aria check back in
with her old season two buddy it's hot
pie so yeah hot pie reminds us that he
was the reason that Brienne was able to
find Aria and free her from the Hound
and him recognizing that she wears armor
is itself a subtle callback to hot pies
past confusion about knights and armors
so if they call Marone it's a battle how
even then moving on to Winterfell John
announces his plans to meet with the
narrative Dragonstone and just like
there was last week in Winterfell here
there's some more interesting subtext in
the reaction shot you're paying close
attention so when John first says
position he turns around to look at
Sansa square in the eyes basically
putting foot down this time against her
openly contradicting him but then also
when John says we need allies the camera
cuts to Littlefinger who yeah would feel
threatened by John saying this because
he probably thinks that the Knights of
the Vale and little figure the only
allies that John would need but by
getting more allies that would weaken
Littlefinger's position as point man
then Sansa does her best admiral ackbar
impression richard promises reminding
everyone in the room that Daenerys his
father the Mad King also summoned their
grandfather
Rickard stark and his son Brandon to
King's Landing and yeah that was a total
trap they got burned to death with
wildfire
what is John thinking well even though
John is probably right to go meet with
Daenerys because it's a character
meeting that we're all dying to see just
like thirsty
try to do in the south these northerners
are using these sins of the father to
judge the child meanwhile this younger
generation is struggling to escape the
shadow of their father and we literally
see John in his father's shadow when we
move on to the crypts beneath Winterfell
in front of the grave of Ned Stark
though we should say this is technically
not John's father it's his uncle but
whatever provocation and I like how even
though John has been trying to be
smarter than Ned was he still lets that
stark sense of honor get the best of
them doing whatever he starte really
wants to do
grab Littlefinger by the throat actually
the framing of the shot is exactly the
same as that seen in season 1 where Ned
grabbed Littlefinger by the throat in
King's Landing
like father like son or like Uncle like
nephew right okay moving on to a huge
reunion that we've been waiting a
million season for Arya finding her
long-lost direwolf of Nymeria who's the
size of a bear now now mariya doesn't
want to join her and Arya's line of
that's not you it's force a callback to
season one when her father Ned was
trying to get her to act more like a
southern style lady that's not me
so Arya is remembering that she never
wanted to be lectured about family duty
or being a good start she wanted to go
her own path so it's only natural that
her direwolf would to Phillip and Maud
actually I have two interesting
interpretations of the scene Westeros
weekly but the way I see it is the
direction of the sea and his super
interesting notice how it begins with
Arya shivering and she breathes its cold
air and a horse is freaking out even
though last week I saw that teaser with
the wolf in this moment it kind of felt
like Arya was about to be surrounded by
White Walkers right either way it's
interesting to see this fear in Arya's
eyes this is the first time she's looked
scared since she left Bravo she's being
reminded of her vulnerability out here
on her own
actually last breakdown we talked about
how Arya's lone wolf confidence was
pretty short-sighted remember the line
in the season 7 trailer with Sansa
quoting Ned Stark from the books
the lone wolf dies and the pack survives
so I think this is significant this is
the first time this lone wolf felt
scared in the wild and at the same time
she's seen how another lone wolf that
she knows survived by forming a pack so
I think this reinforces her need to
return to
back at Winterfell okay moving on to the
final sequence of this episode this
amazing climactic sea battle Greyjoy vs
Greyjoy and maybe this is just me but I
feel like these little scenes leading up
to this battle we're kind of meant to
remind us about the lead-up to the red
wedding notice how characters are
getting foolishly drunk and they're
getting sensual and they're making plans
for the future this is just like how Rob
and Talisa named their son and planned
about teaching little Ned Stark how to
ride horses meanwhile the sand snakes
are bragging about the next step of who
they're going to kill in ilaria and Yara
are talking about becoming queen of the
Iron Islands and getting drunk on
Dornish wine yeah everyone is putting
the cart before the horse here so we
know what's going to happen the arrival
of Euron fleet is awesome
now I will say it's a little unlikely
that a fleet of a thousand ships would
be able to sneak up on them even though
it's pretty foggy I mean it's still a
full moon out there I just attributed to
the fact that Yara and the leaders of
these ships are drunk and distracted and
just too confident now last week we
talked about the design of your on boat
to silence how it has this plow shape
and this front that's designed to wedge
into ships and now we get to see it in
action it does exactly that and now we
see how this top piece work actually
clamped down onto it allowing plunderers
to board the ship and we think about
this design this is actually the jaw of
McCracken that's on the bow of the ship
so they designed it in a way that looks
like the Kraken is eating the ship that
they're attacking so I feel like this
scene really shows us Joran Greyjoy
coming alive he is such a great villain
actually if you look back at your on
last episode we described his look as
this Jack Sparrow rock star type guy but
terms of who he is as a character I feel
like he might be closer to Heath
Ledger's version of the Joker in the
Dark Knight he's so proudly an agent of
chaos like for two episodes characters
have been making these careful plans and
then Euron gleefully smashes them we
even see him laughing like a mad man at
the end of the scene this chaos makes
him feel alive and I think like Heath
Ledger's version of that character I
think you're on energy seems to be that
of a Mad Dog and I think that's
intentional remember earlier in the
episode Varys mentioned how the dogs of
King's Landing wouldn't stop howling
during the last storms and now during
this
this dog is howling with laughter now
you probably noticed that urine is using
a battle-axe in the scene that is a
reference to Victarion Greyjoy's a
character in the book he's your own
brother and he famously used the max now
the carrion isn't in the show but it
seems like they've merged you're on
character in the book with dick Tyrion's
character bringing in details from both
to form this new awesome character now
another little detail here is notice how
you're on guys are cutting out tongues
of the people they're conquering in the
books it's actually what you're on does
to every guy that he conquers he cuts
out their tongues specifically to
prevent them from mutiny against him so
it's not just as barbaric tactic it's
actually got a practical purpose now
there's some great game of Thrones
action in the scene I'll admit it's a
little hard to follow but what they do
really well in this is a Leslie actor's
tell the story kind of like they did
with Jon Snow in the Battle of the
bastards they focus on the emotional
reaction of one character to let us know
what the tide of the battle is
specifically notice Yara's hopeless face
as she sees her fleet burning around her
basically she's telling us in this
moment that the battle is already lost
and then right after this we see Theon
space returning to reek and then when
yara sees that single tear falls from
her cheek basically now she's realizing
the battles lost and her brothers lost
what a question I have here while you're
on was fighting with the sand snakes
their weapons definitely grazed him a
couple times
remember with Bronn in season five just
simply getting nicked by any of those
weapons was enough to poison him so bad
that he need in the antidote otherwise
he would have died so do we think Iran
has been poisoned the promos for next
episode Simba show them alive and well
so probably not the only explanation
that makes sense for me is that maybe
because the same stakes weren't ready
for battle that maybe they hadn't kept
their weapons freshly poison anyway let
me know what you think also last week we
asked the question what we think you're
on gift would be now it seems pretty
clear that that's the reason they kept
ilaria and tyene alive so that Euron can
return to Cersei the mother and daughter
who poisoned her daughter Marcella so
that Cersei can probably return the
favor
or let the mountain have some fun and
that brings us to our closing images so
we see see on on driftwood a broken man
watching as a silence leaves and a huge
part of Daenerys fleet burning and I
think this connects to that idea of what
it means to be Stormborn
now ready talk about how Daenerys had
been kind of
moved from her Stormborn roots but you
know who is Stormborn
the guy who won this battle Joran
Greyjoy the Ironborn believe in the
drowned God they baptize men by holding
them under water and forcing them to
inhale sea water drowning them so that
when they come to they come back harder
and stronger they embrace their fear of
drowning letting the destructive power
of water test them to reveal their true
selves in this episode you're on Greyjoy
embodies this concept more than anyone
in fact remember when he first debuted
on the show he told his brother bail on
that he is the drowned God also you're
on in this moment was born out of the
chaos that a storm ring
he has been officially tested now other
characters in this episode go through
storms of their own that test them as
well
grey worm has to face the only fear he's
ever had losing Masson de and Jorah
Mormont suffers this painful treatment
for his greyscale and yeah I think he
too will come out of this harder and
stronger and then that brings us to see
on now I know it seemed like the
ultimate weak cowardly moved to abandon
his sister and that because it is I
think that's the point jumping in the
water is a baptism of a different sort
for Theon it reveals his true nature and
in this case that true nature isn't
beyond a Greyjoy its reek the lesson
from this is that when we're tested we
don't control the identities that we
become that is what it means to be
Stormborn let me know your thoughts
about this episode and any theories you
have on the questions that I brought up
in the comments below or you can tweet
at us I'm a TA vos or at new rap stars
at new rockstars and specifically if you
have any questions make sure to include
the hashtag Westeros weekly so that
Philip and mod can answer it on their
show also make sure to check out our
breakdown of last week's episode and
stay tuned for a breakdown of next
episode title the Queen's justice big
thanks to all of our donors especially
Chris Kell thank you for watching it's
not crazy about how I do these
breakdowns just know I do anything that
I can follow the round of subscribers
this is Fred
you